dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
日本語が流暢ですねと言いたいときは実は日本語が流暢ですねではなく日本語が
ペラペラですねと言う
日本語ではこうして伝統的な形容詞や副詞の代わりに擬音語や擬態語を使うことが非常
に良い
しかし
イオン5研ぎ daigo が日常的に起こるすべての様子状況をカバーしているわけ
ではないということで今日は新しい擬音語擬態語をつくったり既に存在する擬音語擬態
語に新しい意味をつけたりしてみたいと
ほっそりしている
そしてぽっちゃりしているその間にある人が普通にしている
急いで朝食をとることスターバタバタする味がないさま
セロリとしている絶えず良いものを作ることジブリとする
に対して
わかりやすく展開することなるとする140文字の文書インターネットに投稿すること
を小鳥とする
だから下っ腹が出ている様二バフぱしている
軽く一回転する様もしくは切ない旋律に浸ることをぐるりとする
だからもともと twitter ワーク鳥がなんですねぇー
me
同じ物事を続けざまに勢いよく行う様
例えば60年以上同じ菓子屋ダンスを使ってしよること
ざんざんシーリーよる中途半端に驚くこと
びっくりする多くの人と軽く関係を持つこと
ティンだりするだからもともとその小鳥のさえずり負い目知らない女性の古い写真を
見るなど
sns で怪しい行動をとることいいねいいねする品質よりお金を大事にすることを
生むとする部屋のテーブルや机を新しくは臨時すること
いい飛びする寒い冗談を言うこと
と源とするんん
ni